[Applause]
we gave UDS a new game boy and you gain
to film them and now you say you want a
revolution well we've got one thousands
of watts minute shoppers snagging a we
like a cable car
the demand for Nintendo is going on
Seoul is triggering a long line up
they were giving out the Nintendo Wii
tomorrow morning are you ready
absolutely holder I think so we're gonna
start it at 6:20 and then every 10
minutes you guys are gonna drink I think
it's eight ounces of water how much
longer do you think you should go
Jennifer
um as long as my stomach will continue
to let me I don't know maybe too much
water Jennifer I heard that it's not
you're not doing too well my head hurt
are you telling me that it's the water
that it's my it'll tell me I had to hurt
and then it'll make me puke but who told
you that the intern yeah it makes you it
hurts but it makes me feel light-headed
so I'm not sure if I'm just like this is
what it feels like when you're drowning
there's a lot of water inside of you
as a contestant on 107.9 the end strange
drink two gallons of water in just three
hours hoping to win a Nintendo game
system strange was runner-up but only
hours after going home the Sacramento
County coroner says she died the
apparent victim of water intoxication
the youngest boy Ryland is asking his
grandmother you know when's mommy coming
home and there's just no way to really
answer that question in a fashion that's
satisfactory to a three-year-old what
happens is you get a sex your cognition
affects your judgment that's why they
call it water intoxication yeah there's
a very notorious case in this community
up in Chico north of here where a young
man was subjected and in a fraternity
circumstan where they forced him to
drink water and he died of water
intoxication really with that before or
out before this and local people at the
radio station knew about this and they
actually when they were talking among
themselves and talking to the public not
to the contestants they remembered they
talked about this case with a gentleman
by name of Matt Carrington and they
actually said gee can't someone die from
this maybe we should have done more
research Oh water poisoning and like die
your body is 90% water why can't you
take in as much water shoo ha they got
phone calls yeah from nurses that we're
telling them you can you can die from
this what you're putting people through
Eva yes what do you want to say that
those people that are drinking on that
water can do sick and possibly die from
water intoxication yeah we're aware of
that we releases so we're not
responsible it's ok and if they get to
the point where they have to throw up
and they're gonna throw up and they're
out of the contest before they die so
that's good right yeah all right do you
go how come you guys been doing we don't
wanna die ok let me ask hey Carter is
anybody is anybody dying in there we got
about to die
good make sure we laugh at the insurance
on that plea and all the contestants
feel and believe they're gonna be
drinking water and holding their urine
they don't understand that they're being
compressed in time the literally
drinking a lethal dose of water Jennifer
had she gotten it care was already well
past based upon the autopsy well past
the point of no return she would had
severe brain injury okay she would have
been basically a vegetable
radio DJ Lucas whose real name is Adam
Cox says he carried out the contest on
management's orders he says he didn't
believe it was potentially deadly I
don't really don't think that we did
anything wrong we just did our jobs a
woman is dead yes lost your job but she
lost her life correct I feel horrible
for her and her family absolutely
horrible that's one of our listeners
died and never thought for one second
that we were gonna get fired not for one
second did I think that we were gonna
get fired and why not because it wasn't
our fault we didn't do anything wrong we
just did what we were told to do these
people knew of the potential lethal
effect of what they were putting these
people to they hadn't shared it with the
contestants right they knew and when
they got these calls in that we're
telling them you know people can die the
reaction was to joke about it again to
be edgy that they feel would develop
their ratings and have people listen if
someone had said the f-word yeah or it
said the S word yeah on this then they
pull their license but if you kill
somebody because you failed to do the
research and you failed to do your job
you can keep you know pumping out the
commercial dollar